وفقا للعلم يجب مراعاه بعض الاشياء قبل
تشغيل الموسيقى لتعزيز الانتاجيه اولها
تحديد موسيقى مناسبه لكل مهمه حتى لا
تستنزف طاقتك العقليه اولها اعداد قائمه
من الموسيقى لاستخدامها اثناء المهام
الممله وهنا ينصح المختصون بموسيقى مبهجه
بايقاع سريع واغاني البوب بشكل خاص
الموسيقى الكلاسيكيه مرشحه دائما في مختلف
الابحاث وهناك نظريه علميه يطلق عليها
تاثير تقول ان الاستماع الى موسيقى
موتزارد مفيد لتعزيز نشاط الدماغ ورفع
معدل الذكاء المكاني الموسيقى التصويريه
للافلام خاصه الافلام الملحميه واعمال
دراما الحروب التاريخيه تاخذك في رحله
تشعر معها وكانك تغير العالم وبالتالي من
المحتمل ان تزيد من انتاجيتك في النهايه
عند تعلم شيء جديد او الدخول في مشروع
معقد بالعمل يفضل حينها تجنب الاستماع الى
الموسيقى في البدايه وبشكل عام لا ينصح
بال استماع الى الموسيقى طوال ذلك اليوم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات